patrick you and i did this show a very
long time ago like you're an original
gangster of this show
that's right
totally and
you know i was wondering what you were
going to wear
but my goodness do you just deliver
oh thank you i'm so excited to be here
it's funny i think a lot of us got the
memo on like hey let's throw some color
at this weather
yes you know let's boost our mood um i
mean you are really crushing it right
now
how does it feel
i mean it's just crazy um i have a few
billboards out right now my beauty brand
one size and i just feel so loved and
for you to even have me on here is such
a huge honor it's just crazy i'm so
excited um i mean
you've worked with some beautiful
extraordinary famous faces
is there somebody that you haven't
worked with or are going to work with
that you're excited about
well i've always wanted to work with
oprah mother oh
and paint her or just have a chat with
her but i mean here today while i have a
celebrity
i would love
to be lucky enough to get my makeup done
by you that would be such an honor thank
you thank you i'm such a huge fan of you
we actually facetimed when we did when i
did it for halloween and you jumped on
facetime with us i will
is drew bae more going to really answer
our call absolutely my brother was like
is she gonna answer
absolutely i love to play and i love
what you do because i feel like i've
grown up in a makeup chair and a hair
and makeup trailer my whole life and i
really feel like i got
some really important messaging on what
beauty is and to me it was always about
these women and men who walked in early
in the morning or you know just kind of
like furled in and through the
transformation of hair and makeup they
would
and they would walk out different yes
and
as an impressionable young child
i was like that's what beauty is it's an
empowerment it's
it's something that
happens on the inside it's a feeling and
it's an empowerment so we have your
products here which i'm really excited
about how did you come up with the uh
name one size i was told to not be
myself my whole life growing up i even
went to work and i was asked to take off
my makeup by my manager and i remember a
year later and i was shopping and i
couldn't fit any clothes in the in the
store and i said you know what i can't
buy anything here
but you know i can buy makeup because
makeup is a one size fits all so
being um a man in makeup i
coined the you know i use that as our
tagline and one size beauty represents
everyone and everywhere i go i try to
wear as much red
to represent love not just for each
other but for yourself and i feel like
more than ever soft love is like the
hardest thing it is it is the hardest
thing now your parents are here yes yes
they're here
[Applause]
of course
um the lady in the pink trench who i
commented on the second i came out here
how fitting you are patrick's mom yeah
that's my dad that's mike hi
hi
how are you
i'm well thank you we're so excited
first we love you oh i love you guys and
i love your son so very much thank you
[Laughter]
thank you
what was patrick like as a kid may i ask
he is very
graceful
loving
nurturing
and very creative
and
is it true that you share makeup tips
with your mom
i mean she shares all of my makeup my
clothes i think that's mine by the way
she's learned everything under the sun
and i've learned a lot from them in
terms of like how to love yourself
embracing culture
loving others but i think they've
learned a tip or two for for beauty um i
was wondering as a father how are you
pride wise like what was patrick like in
your eyes as a child
we love him so much we're so proud of
everything that we that he's doing for
everybody not only for us
such a beautiful gift it really is i'm
not gonna take this moment for granted
because
you know i i just think it's a gift if
you get to have that kind of
dialogue and energy with your parents
let's never take this for granted
i think it's important to use social
media as a stage and a platform and at
first i was like i'm not going to show
my filipino parents on social media but
then i think once people saw or heard
languages in the back that resonated
with them or saw food and culture
i think that's why i've amassed millions
of views because we've been able to
leverage something so different
that not many lgbtq kids can have so by
showing them they find refuge and
comfort and viewing my channel and
viewing happiness and seeing the energy
and the dynamic that we have is just so
special that people are able to see that
in us also you have so much to teach as
a family you know i mean whether it's
about love
or it's about mad skills
and you have
mad skills
[Music]
you